[Música]
en nicaragua los sandinistas celebraron
el aniversario número 43 del triunfo de
la revolución sobre la dictadura de
anastasio somoza debayle en los festejos
se dan cuando gozan de más poder que
nunca a nivel político y militar tenemos
análisis
de nuevo el presidente de perú cambia a
su ministro del interior se trata del
sexto funcionario en esa oficina desde
que pero el castillo llegó al poder hace
menos de un año tenemos información
desde el ine
nuevos hallazgos en el caso de de baní
escobar quien fue encontrada sin vida en
abril en el estado de nuevo léon en
méxico una tercera autopsia determinó
que la joven murió de asfixia por
sofocación lo que descarta las versiones
anteriores que sugerían que había
fallecido por una contusión profunda de
cráneo
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en nicaragua donde
el gobernante partido frente sandinista
de liberación nacional celebró su
aniversario número 43 de su revolución
cuando derrocaron al dictador anastasio
somoza debayle a la cabeza del
presidente daniel ortega los sandinistas
cuentan con más poder que nunca a nivel
político y militar y sin ningún
contrapeso ya que la oposición se ha
visto diezmada por el encarcelamiento y
el exilio para analizar este tema saludo
en el estudio a mi compañero jorge
hurtado la redacción de france 24 quien
fue es periodista nicaragüense y fue
nuestro corresponsal en managua jorge en
qué contexto celebra el sandinismo su
aniversario número 43 de la revolución
andrew definitivamente lo hace en
solitario ya que importantes figuras de
la revolución de hace 43 años como dora
maría téllez o víctor hugo tinoco están
detenidos tras distanciarse de ortega y
apoyar las protestas opositoras
ortega celebró este aniversario con un
reducido grupo de seguidores en la plaza
de la revolución de managua lo hizo
rodeado principalmente de suministro
familia policías militares
invitados internacionales sobre todo la
mayoría de bajo perfil y es que varios
países del mundo acusan a ortega de
dirigir un régimen autoritario en
nicaragua todo después de que la
represión en las revueltas sociales de
2018 dejarán más de 350 muertos el
gobierno de ortega justificó la
violencia diciendo que se defendían de
un golpe de estado pero hoy en día esa
crisis ha dejado más de 200 mil
exiliados 190 presos políticos y más de
1000 organizaciones de sociedad civil
anuladas países como cuba venezuela
honduras san vicente y las granadinas
rusia felicitaron y saludaron al
gobierno de ortega también lo hizo el
líder norcoreano kim yong ortega que
tiene 76 años lleva 15 años y cinco
meses consecutivos en el poder
marcado por denuncias de corrupción y
violaciones a los derechos humanos por
ge muchas gracias por traer esta
radiografía de la situación política y
social que vive nicaragua y cambiamos de
tema y vamos a panamá porque siguen las
manifestaciones que ya se han extendido
por más de dos semanas y luego de que se
rompiera el acuerdo al que las
organizaciones sociales habían llegado
con el gobierno
de acuerdo con el sector privado las
protestas y bloqueos de carreteras han
generado pérdidas de alrededor de 500
millones de dólares a los productores
agropecuarios y a la agroindustria han
provocado además la escasez de
combustible y alimentos en algunas zonas
del país
previamente hablamos con el viceministro
de desarrollo agropecuarios
carlos romanín quien hizo en france24 un
llamado a avanzar en el diálogo aquí hay
un componente político vuelvo y repito
lo entendemos sin embargo consideramos
que en este momento no hay ninguna
justificación para mantener los cierres
de calle hay un llamado que ha hecho la
iglesia católica para reunirnos
nuevamente y nosotros como gobierno
estamos dispuestos a seguir abordando
estos temas entendiendo que el costo de
la vida y el costo de los alimentos es
algo que nos preocupa y estamos seguros
que a través del diálogo vamos a llegar
a la mejor solución posible y no paran
las polémicas en el gobierno peruano el
presidente pedro castillo anunció la
salida del ministro del interior mariano
gonzález quien estuvo dos semanas en el
cargo y es el sexto funcionario en
abandonar esta oficina desde que
castillo llegó al poder en julio de 2021
para ampliar esta noticia saludamos en
lima a nuestro corresponsal francisco
zacarías francisco a qué se debe la
salida del ahora ex ministro gonzález
buenas noches en realidad todo se
suscita tras un escándalo que el
empresario samir villaverde es testigo
protegido de la justicia peruana en las
investigaciones que realiza la fiscalía
por presunta corrupción al presidente
pedro casi o samir vía verde denunció
que era objeto de una persecución un
seguimiento por efectivos del servicio
de inteligencia de la policía él
denunció que el ministerio del interior
estaba haciendo esto para evitar que él
siga colaborando con la justicia peruana
esto suscitó un escándalo y el
presidente pedro castillo decidió
retirar al ministro del cargo y es así
que ha nombrado a willy huerta como
nuevo representante de esta cartera en
casi 12 meses de gestión que lleva a
castillo ahora el nuevo reto de este
ministro huerta va a ser recuperar la
confianza de la población conseguir la
captura del ex secretario bruno pacheco
y de los sobrinos del presidente pedro
castillo que son fray vázquez y
gianmarco castillo quienes se encuentran
prófugos de la justicia esta situación
pone serios el presidente pero que ha
sido quien nueve días va a cumplir en su
primer año de gestión y cuenta con una
desaprobación del 74 por ciento de la
población francisco zacarías es de lima
gracias por ese reporte vamos a méxico
porque se conocen nuevos detalles del
caso desde baní escobar la joven cuyo
cuerpo fue encontrado en un pozo en el
estado norteño de nuevo león en abril de
acuerdo con los resultados de una
tercera autopsia escobar murió de
asfixia por sofocación lo que contradice
los hallazgos anteriores del estado y
aumentan las dudas sobre las
investigaciones
se conocieron los resultados de una
tercera autopsia en el caso de de baní
escobar la joven de 18 años desaparecida
cuando regresaba a su casa de una fiesta
el pasado 9 de abril en monterrey que la
causa de muerte de evans y susana
escobar basaldúa se debió a una asfixia
por sofocación en su variedad de
obstrucción de orificios respiratorios
el caso se convirtió en un escándalo
nacional por las múltiples
incongruencias de las autoridades
tardaron casi dos semanas en encontrar
su cuerpo en el tanque de un motel
cercana a la carretera donde fue vista
por última vez
inicialmente sugirieron que escobar
murió por una contusión después de caer
por error al pozo pero una segunda
autopsia realizada por investigadores
privados contratados por la familia de
bani concluyó que había sido agredida
sexualmente
versión que también fue negada en esta
tercera revisión tras exhumar el cuerpo
la tercera conclusión es el hecho de que
no se encontró ninguna evidencia ningún
tipo de lesión hallazgo que pudiera
sustentar violencia sexual y la última
es que se descartó por completo la
posibilidad de una asfixia por sumersión
en medio de las incongruencias su padre
ha sido una figura importante en los
cuestionamientos en una búsqueda de
justicia queremos decirles mi esposa y
yo
que seguimos
buscando la verdad como comentaba el
fiscal
que seguimos en la lucha
saber qué fue lo que le pasó a de
o'neill
la historia de the bank ya escobar se
sumó a una serie de otras desapariciones
en la región que provocaron protestas en
todo méxico donde se estima que 10
mujeres son asesinadas cada día
venezuela es el país con la tasa de
embarazos adolescentes más alta de toda
américa latina' con 96 casos por cada
1.000 mujeres de entre 15 y 19 años el
país duplica el promedio de la región
son los datos que reporta el fondo de
población de las naciones unidas- en
venezuela desde este estamento
destacaron sin embargo la implementación
como política pública de un plan para
reducir estos embarazos en los 11
municipios que registran la mayor
incidencia
en eeuu la cámara de representantes
aprobó un proyecto de ley que protege
los el matrimonio entre parejas del
mismo sexo y parejas interraciales a
nivel federal en medio de la
preocupación despertada por la decisión
de la corte suprema de revertir el
derecho al aborto defensores de derechos
humanos temen que el tribunal de mayoría
conservadora tome otra decisión similar
y revierta el derecho al matrimonio
igualitario
hasta que esta emisión de noticias en
france 24 gracias por acompañarnos los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
www punto
4 punto com para seguir la actualización
de nuestras noticias continúan con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]